Barry focus metahuman I am so dead
captain Singh is going to kill me just
look at this
our very first external metahuman
sighting I'm calling her vixen
hey everybody its Charlie so new episode
of vixen we finally get to see Barry
Oliver and Cisco in full cartoon glory
we even kind of see Nathan Fillion as
Green Lantern but he's off in the
distance if they say his name enough
that he will appear magically like
Candyman if he didn't catch that that
was almost like they were making fun of
themselves like almost like the the CW
Universal shows is making fun of the
fact that they can't do Green Lantern I
know I know Co City would be way cooler
it's all in good fun
it's like Ted Kord on arrow if Stephen
Amell actually ends up making it to
Saturday Night Live that would actually
be a fun joke otherwise I think if they
did like a Candyman you know like say
his name in the mirror a bunch of times
he would probably just say Batman he'd
probably go for full batfleck and they
try to get him to guest star
I actually think you'd be pretty doable
to get Ben Affleck to do a guest spot on
Saturday Night Live if Stephen Amell
hosted but the episode is really about
them finding the first external
metahuman outside of Central City
outside of like the initial blast radius
of the particle accelerator explosion if
you remember during arrow season 3 we
met death bolt he shot the energy beams
out of his eyes the reason that vixen is
the first external metahuman that they
call out is because this is supposed to
take place around arrow season 3 episode
16 we didn't see death bolt till arrow
episode 19 so technically the timeline
still holds up there's also the fact
that Oliver's wearing his old arrow
costume and Barry still has the old
symbol he doesn't he doesn't have like a
white flash symbol that he's got this
year but some of you guys might also
remember that the software that Cisco
used in this episode that he said he got
from Felicity's like Felicity gave me
her tracking software that's the same
software that Ray Palmer used to
identify Oliver as the arrow
he took Felicity software and turned it
into an x-ray vision type of thing so he
could see through walls and identify
people on the spot but if you haven't
watched that first episode of vixen a
little while
this kind of syncs up with the beginning
of that first episode they start noting
that chasing and then they cut to three
days in the past so she's running out of
the frame at the end of episode three
just imagine her running into frame in
episode one but we're still waiting for
is for her to run into her family from
Africa there are three more episodes so
I'm assuming next week is when we'll
meet them there's a more recent vixen
miniseries that kind of does a
reimagining of her origin story and
retcons a few things from the classic
comics but essentially part of her
biological family are really bad people
trying to take the
from her we'll see how the cartoon
series presents them usually it's the
uncle that's the evil one but I haven't
seen any evidence that that's gonna be
the case in the cartoon series it looks
like a female character that's
relatively close to her age so it might
be her cousin and everybody's wondering
about the flash trailer I'm just
guessing that Barry lost it on that
thumb drive that he's trying to find for
Captain Singh that actually be pretty
good marketing for them to use on their
Twitter account we want to give you guys
the season 2 trailer but Barry lost it
on the thumb drive we're looking all
over the place for it normally they post
new trailers in the morning but since we
haven't seen it yet the worst case
scenario like worst possible scenario
they wait till September 22nd when the
DVD gets released I don't think they'll
wait that long they let Steven Amell
show the arrow trailer at DragonCon
like that was the reason that it aired
on Friday because that's when the cast
was at DragonCon
even Grant Gustin on his Twitter account
has said I want to see the trailer too
so I don't think they're gonna wait a
whole week and a half to post it just be
ready for it to come anytime you guys
can follow me on Twitter and Facebook
cuz usually that's where I post stuff
like that first there has been a lot of
news for some of the other DC shows like
Gotham and Supergirl so I might do a
video for those soon be sure to
subscribe to get that stuff if there's
anything specifically you guys want me
to do for those shows just let me know
I'm not super happy with the way their
marketing Supergirl I think the TV show
is gonna be fine but they're marketing
it more as a romantic comedy and I don't
think that that's gonna be the case
that's always the problem marketing news
shows like they want it to be super
different from the shows that are
already on the air like they don't want
it to be exactly like the flash or
exactly like arrow or exactly like
Gotham so they have to market it as
being something different of all the DC
shows that are on the air right now
I think it shares the most in common
with the flash just in terms of its
humor and the way it deals with powers
but that's not gonna premiere till a
couple weeks after air on flash comeback
though they'll be there'll be plenty of
time to talk about that just in case you
guys didn't know Gotham season 2 is
gonna be the first DC show to come back
that's gonna be in two weeks now I'll do
a couple more Gotham bonus videos before
that comes back so no worries there huh
while you guys wait for that you can
click here to watch the arrow season 4
trailer again and you can click here for
the agents of shield season 3 trailer
thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight